if a washing machine robot or retirement
lottery winners sound like can't miss
material then check out these 2022 movie
dramas that flew under the radar
Steve pink might not be the biggest name
in Showbiz but he did direct the cult
classic comedies accepted and Hot Tub
Time Machine it turns out he also has a
knack for drama based on the candid and
touching the wheel which is about a
young couple on the verge of divorce
Alby and Walker met when they were 12
and fell for each other hard as the
wheel begins their eight-year long
marriage is dangerously close to
complete collapse so they rent an Airbnb
cabin from a lovely couple in the woods
to give their Union One Last Shot with
the guide of a dime a dozen self-help
book Walker wants Alby to go through a
set of questions over the weekend but
she isn't exactly keen on participating
as she's really just waiting for the
perfect moment to end their relationship
during all this the owners of the cabin
begin to interfere with their guests
marital issues which only makes matters
worse what makes the wheel worthy of
Praise are the central performances by
Amber mid Thunder and Taylor Gray whose
chemistry is palpable as their
character's opposite personalities Clash
the result is a heartbreakingly honest
drama where we get hurt just as much as
they do by the time the credits start to
roll a veteran of several Ricky Gervais
projects David Earl is a familiar face
to fans of British comedy he usually
plays shy introverted and often
miserable outcasts who are inherently
funny and relatable by Design in the Jim
Archer directed feature Brian and
Charles Earl delivers another variation
of his typically quirky and pathetic
Persona the film follows Earl as a
lonely man named Bryant who lives by
himself in a village in the Welsh
Countryside he spends most of his days
Scavenging scrap and using whatever he
can find to build odd things that nobody
really needs one day he stumbles Upon A
mannequin's head along with an old
broken washing machine which leads to
him building a robot the thing doesn't
work at first but after a stormy night
the robot mysteriously comes alive and
learns to communicate and Brian names
him Charles what follows is a weird but
sweet friendship between an amusing
machine and an isolated man who longed
for a companion his whole life but never
had one until now Brian and Charles
humor is delightfully strange and
awkward but its most endearing aspect is
how it depicts a touching benevolence
underneath its protagonist's trauma in
softly solved
[Laughter]
ah right it's a little surprising that a
neo-western like Montana story didn't
appeal to a larger audience despite
generally positive reviews this tragic
and Untamed American family drama
featuring Haley Lou Richardson and Owen
Teague remains a Hidden Gem perhaps
that's because it's emotionally Raw
Story doesn't go easy on the heart Aaron
played by Richardson and Cal played by
Teague are two estranged siblings who
went their separate ways after a rough
and abusive childhood now after many
years Aaron returns to the ranch that
she abandoned to escape her violent
alcoholic father while she ran away Cal
stayed behind and now he's the one who
looks after their dying dad and takes
care of everything around the ranch
Aaron only comes back to say goodbye but
she ends up staying longer than she
expected during that time she and Cal
confront their past and the demons that
still haunt them now they're both ready
to confess their mistakes and the
regrets they buried deep in their hearts
long ago Montana story can be
challenging at times but if you can
endure its bitter emotional Dynamics
it's a rewarding watch it seems that
every time Zac Efron tries to show off
his act acting skills in a role that
demands more from him than being
handsome and Charming the Stars just
never quite align but maybe we should
give him more credit and the survival
drama gold is just the latest reason why
director Anthony Hayes dystopian vision
is a one-man show for the most part
Virgil played by Ephron is a traveler in
the near future who pays a local man
named Keith played by Hayes to transport
him into an area called The Compound on
their way they discover a large gold
nugget in the desert stuck underground
they decide to take it with them but no
matter how hard they try it just won't
budge so Keith convinces Virgil to stay
behind and guard their newly found
treasure until he gets back with the
right equipment to dig it out what
follows are several days in the desert
filled with unbearable heat scavengers
and local Predators Virgil's mental
state begins to crack and it becomes
doubtful whether he can make it until
his partner returns pafferon delivers a
powerful performance as his character
slowly breaks down physically and
mentally you feel his suffering and root
for him with all your heart despite the
unbalanced pacing and flawed script
ephron's effort comes through making
gold and underrated gem that's worth a
watch take it easy breathe
that's it Jerry and Marge go large is
one of the most Charming delightful
dramedies of the year it's low-key yet
exciting funny and even moving it's an
unbelievable story told in an unfussy
way that lack of heightened drama might
be why it never took off but the
moderate pacing combined with restrained
performances from veterans Brian
Cranston and Annette Benning fit the
tone and script perfectly Jerry and
Marge are a long married couple who have
just entered retirement workaholic Jerry
simply doesn't know what to do with all
the Newfound free time he suddenly has
after working for the same company 42
years but then he finds a loophole in a
lottery game called windfall to find out
whether his theory Works in practice he
buys a lot of tickets he ends up winning
but he's afraid to tell his wife since
they don't have much money saved for
their golden years but when Marge finds
out accidentally she sees an opportunity
to spice up their marriage so she joins
him on a journey that ends up bringing
them a lot of cash and a shot not just
at changing their lives but also the
town they love wholeheartedly Jerry and
Marge got so-so reviews and that might
be the most common opinion from General
audiences as well it's hard not to like
this lovely little gem even if it can't
give you everything to fall in love with
it on a first watch
Jerry and Marge is fine as they made us
me and B Alex directorial debut features
a set of great actors and a delicate
portrayal of a Jewish Family spending
their last days with their dying father
while his physical and mental health
rapidly deteriorates Diana egron plays
Abigail the daughter caretaker and glue
of the family she's also a single mother
raising two kids while trying to take
care of her elderly father Eugene played
by Dustin Hoffman she has an awful lot
on her plate and her mother is more of
an obstacle than a helper Abigail
genuinely cares about her dad despite
the rough intraumatic upbringing he put
her and her brother through when death
comes scarily close for Eugene Abigail
gives it one last shot to convince her
brother to say goodbye to their father
while he still can as they made us
slowly Works its way through your heart
and crushes it Hoffman gives a
performance for the ages while everyone
else around him is just as solid there
aren't any big surprises in this drama
but it's so well written and acted that
it doesn't need them I I didn't
necessarily want to write it I felt it
to write some of these things down after
putting in the hard work as a supporting
actor for three decades Clifton Collins
Jr proved more than capable to carry an
entire film on his shoulders jockey is a
fantastic Soulful movie that doesn't
only do justice to Collins but also to a
sport that's been mistreated so many
times on screen before Collins plays
Jackson Silva who's been a jockey his
whole life horse racing is in his blood
and despite the several serious injuries
he suffered during his career he doesn't
want to retire after all he isn't really
good at anything else and he knows
horses better than people but he can't
reverse time and what it's done to his
body that doesn't mean he won't try
though with the help of a skillful
trainer named Ruth he decides to take
part in the upcoming Championship that
will most likely be his last if he can
finish it at all what he can't be
prepared for though is the racing
newcomer who claims to be his son jockey
is a superb drama with a Sublime
atmosphere that not only does right by
the world of horse racing but gives us a
chance to feel like we're a part of it
in a perfect world The Survivor would
have been a TV film produced by HBO but
instead of big budget Studio flick that
would earn Ben Foster his first Oscar
nomination but in reality this biopic
about Holocaust Survivor Harry haft is a
trauma that flew under the radar even
though critics praised it upon its
release the plot follows half post-world
War II on his road to becoming a
professional boxer after surviving the
concentration camps by fighting his
fellow inmates to death besides making a
living his goal is to gain enough
publicity to find his long-lost love who
was separated from him during the war as
he continuously grapples with his past
trauma we see flashbacks of him in the
camps depicting how he stayed alive
though the Survivor is a little uneven
as it ambitiously attempts to cover
several decades of half's tumultuous
life Fosters exceptional performance is
what pulls it together he's a little too
old to play half in his younger years
but it doesn't feel that way he
convincingly conveys all the anger and
Terror he went through in horrifying
experiences that left him with
survivor's guilt murdered your own
people
oh I like this
one moment is perhaps most notable as
the final film for legendary character
actor Danny Aiello who passed away in
2019 after a brief illness his
performance as Joe McGinnis couldn't
have been more fitting as a recently
widowed husband Joe tries to cope with
the loss of his wife by becoming more
present in his middle aged children's
lives the plot follows the three
McGinnis siblings and how they operate
their overwhelmingly busy lives besides
working and raising kids they're also
trying to comfort their ailing father
who struggles with increasingly physical
and mental health issues it provides an
excellent opportunity for Aiello to
Showcase his subtle and Charming skills
one last time even at the age of 86
Aiello delivers the kind of performance
that made him one of the most memorable
character actors around during an almost
50 year long career the rest of the cast
does a good job but none of them can
quite rise to Aiello's level as an
experienced veteran he's the heart of
the movie and the one who makes it all
work comedian Gerard Carmichael's
feature directorial debut on the count
of three is a dromedy exploring mental
health and trauma with pitch black humor
and a raw emotional palette the plot
follows Carmichael and Christopher
Abbott AS Val and Kevin two best friends
at the end of their ropes Val is
depressed dreading life at his mundane
job after receiving a promotion he walks
to the bathroom and tries to hang
himself but gets interrupted meanwhile
Kevin is in a psychiatric hospital after
a suicide attempt trying to convince a
social worker that he doesn't have
suicidal thoughts anymore when Val shows
up to Kevin and asks him to run away
together Kevin doesn't hesitate once
they flee Val suggests they should help
kill each other he's thought of
everything two handguns in a backpack in
abandoned parking lot behind a strip
club and an unchangeable determination
to go through with it on the count of
three tackles mental health issues
without Illusions it's a poignant and
realistic depiction of people
experiencing Suicidal Thoughts with
Grace and empathy if you or anyone you
know is having suicidal thoughts please
call the National Suicide Prevention
Lifeline by dialing 988 or by calling
1-800-273-talk
[Music]
thank you